eggh now is with us in Arizona right now
how are you hey pleasure to talk to you
how are you better than I deserve what's
up
great great I'm just gonna keep this
short and sweet as possible I'm 24
I make 66 grand a year I'm a dental
hygienist
I'm in a lot of debt 3,000 on a person
alone nine thousand on a car
twenty-one thousand on my student loans
and a hundred thirty thousand on a
Parent PLUS loan I work at a IHS
facility so they give me eighteen
thousand a year for a loan repayment the
problem that I have is the Parent PLUS
loan
increased from two hundred dollars to
eight hundred seventy dollars because my
mother has no more dependents living
with her and so I can't really make that
payment until my debt snowball gets a
little bit bigger so the way I can kind
of postpone those payments for the PLUS
loan is to take the eighteen grand that
I got from loan repayment and kind of
paid ahead on that loan so I was just
wondering whether I should take that
eighteen grand and put it towards all my
federal student loans the twenty one
grand so I can get closer to the plan
PLUS loan with the debt snowball or just
postpone the Parent PLUS loan as well
okay um I don't know why on 66,000
you can't make the payments well the
thing is it'll be it would be a very
very very tight well I feel like I can
make them yes have you done an actual
budget yes I have okay what is your read
how much is your rent 900 a month how
much is your car payment 180 okay you
have 21,000 student loans and three
thousand and one hundred and thirty
thousand you're picking up the Parent
PLUS loan even though it's your mom's
loan correct and that was your agreement
with her yeah
um she and your dental hygienist yes sir
so you're working 40 yes okay
well by extra job I do ruber on the
weekends yeah but what about a night um
that's about it you know five yeah and I
go to the gym after work and by the time
I get home from work I'm exhausted
because my commute is an hour well your
mom needs our Parent PLUS loan paid so I
guess you're not going to gym I guess
you're going to work hoping not to hear
that if you want to go to the gym you
have to tighten up something else in the
budget correct you know there's only two
sides this equation income and outgo and
what you're doing what you're talking
about doing this eighteen thousand is
just you're playing hide and seek here
and eventually you're gonna get found
so I mean you're just delaying the
inevitable you're just screwing around
trying to hide the pea under the shell
and it's still under one of the shells
so what I want to do is create a
sustainable plan where you're able to
attack this long-term did you get 18,000
and a lump sum yes it went literally 18
grand and it's sitting in your account
yes well why don't you pay off your car
and the three thousand dollar loan and a
bunch of the twenty one thousand dollar
loan well I want to keep it towards the
student loans why is that what they gave
it big that's what they gave the money
to me the faster you get everything paid
off the faster you're gonna go on the
student loans right right right
I just didn't know whether I was I mean
I'm sure I can pay off the car with it
very Canada you know money's in your
account I'm sorry the money's in your
account you can do what you want it's
not illegal believe me it's just the
point is is that we are going to pay off
the student loans and we are going to
push this on through so let's see nice
twelve years any 6060 so yummy dude like
by right after Christmas with you
working your butt off you could be dead
free except the Parent PLUS loan and you
have all kinds of room in your budget
right so you take a quarter off from the
gym and you kick this thing in the butt
all right have you paid off the three
thousand our loan the car loan and the
student loan by Christmas with this
eighteen and was working your butt off
and you can do all of that there are
only six thousand off and this is
September so I'm not getting in the head
man you can do this and then then you're
sitting there staring this Parent PLUS
loan down now we got a little bit of a
slog going here take a while to get
through that puppy but is there any side
gigs for hygienists I can possibly pick
up a Saturday shift but a morning
Saturday more than uber right and I can
do ooh BRR after the Saturday no you
don't just do more Saturday you get paid
more for being a hygienist than you do
delivering goop's
right right right yeah that's true so go
be a hot Genesis there's more money in
that man that's why you got trained you
should use the skills in turn because of
what we're trying to hear just create
some money and and my rule in my life
has been I'm band-aid off fast guy work
like nobody else so later you can work
like nobody else live like nobody else
so later you can live and give like
nobody else and I appreciate the honor
of you wanting to do the right thing by
this money and really appreciate the
honor of you're doing the right thing by
your mom yeah you're good man thank you
thank you if I can help you call me back
but that's what I would do if I woke up
in your shoes I'd get after it man and
I'd be done with this crap everything
but the parent plus my Christmas and and
then I would I would lay into that on a
steady grind and work your way through
it's gonna take a while
130,000 making sixty you don't have to
get your income up and that thing's
gonna be hanging around longer than you
wanted it to I like him good guy
I like his heart but I'm gonna kick his
mother's butt if your mom you don't sit
down and look at your kid and say hey
honey let's go 150,000 dollars in debt
so you can make 60 cleaning tea
dumb butt decision okay not picking on
him but you know mom come on do some
math here it's basics the return on
investment there is ridiculous you can
become a hygienist a lot cheaper two
hundred fifty grand to start with but
second there's nothing wrong with being
a hygienist I'm really glad you guys are
out there please don't hurt me next time
I'm in there but um but you know that
but the point is that you you any time
you're looking at a degree field you
don't spend just whatever the flip you
want to spend because it's all gonna
work out because I got a degree this is
the whole thing it's why we got this
whole borrowed future debt-free degree
thing going we have us I hate student
loan movement going with Anthony O'Neill
right now and I check out the new
podcast borrowed future it's exploding
people are going crazy over this new
thing it's uncovering the student loan
crisis but that's exactly what happens
is nobody looks at the math in these
decisions look at the math in these
decisions
cuz everybody strapped here mom's
stressed worried about this loan cuz
junior done paid she's saddled with it
juniors trying to do the right thing
step up take care of momma he's a good
man he's a good guy y'all that's a good
guy right there